t
tétéléphone moins forfaits
cecellulaire.
- - C'était une décision très
atattendue au Canada et ailleur.
MeMerci. Jean-François Lépine,
anancien directeur des
rereprésentations du Québec en
ChChine. Bonsoir. Est-ce que les
ChChinois vont refaire un tour e
mamanège de leur colère envers e
CaCanada? Est-ce qu'on doit
s's'attendre à des représailles?
- - Je pense qu'il va y avoir ds
réréactions négatives. Il faut
imimaginer que la Chine est
acactuellement est débordée de
prproblème. La COVID, une crise
mamajeure dans tout le pays, la
guguerre en Ukraine dans laquele
lala Chine s'est positionnée et
ququi lui a beaucoup nui à travs
lele monde et puis l'économie
chchinoise, qui en conséquence e
ceces deux phénomènes là, est en
rerecul. Ça ne va pas bien. Il a
auaussi des élections qui s'en
viviennent au sein du parti
cocommuniste chinois pour
l'l'obtention de la part du
prprésident de troisième mandat.
OnOn aurait dit que le Canada a
pepeut-être attendu cette
sisituation délibérément. Ce n't
pepeut-être pas vrai. C'est sûr
quque la Chine a d'autres
prpréoccupations et elle a surtt
nene préoccupations importantes:
elelle a perdu dans son appui àa
guguerre en Ukraine, l'appui dea
FrFrance et des États-Unis. Elle
nene peut pas se payer le luxe e
sese mettre à dos un autre paysn
adadoptant des mesures qui
seseraient extraordinaires. Il
fafaut dire une chose inouïe. Ps
plplus tard qu'hier, la Chine
anannonçait que les restrictions
ququi avaient été imposées
ququelques mois après
l'l'arrestation de Madame Meng
WaWanzhou sur les importations
chchinoises de grains de canolau
CaCanada dorénavant vont tomber.
LeLes importations de canola vot
popouvoioir atteindre leur niveu
nonormal d'avant l'arrestation e
MaMadame Meng Wanzhou. Il y a un
cocontexte qui illustre à quel
popoint les Chinois ont besoin s
tetemps-ci d'ouvrir les vannes
plplutôt que de les fermer.
- - Sur le fond de l'histoire, r
leles craintes que les occidentx
onont face à Huawei, est-ce que
c'c'est largement admis, c'est
prpresque une évidence pour
plplusieurs Huawei aurait pu se
seservir de sa technologie pour
fafaire de l'espionnage?
- - Oui, ça n'a pas empêché
bebeaucoup de payer d'utiliser a
tetechnologie et les services de
HuHuawei, même certains pays en
EuEurope, mais la plupart des ps
ququi partagent nos valeurs et s
prpréoccupations de sécurité ont
adadopté des mesures contre.
L'L'annonce d'aujourd'hui porte
susur les technologies et servis
dede Huawei, mais aussi de ZTE,
ququi est une compagnie chinoise
ququi a probablement les mêmes
liliens avec les autorités
chchinoises et l'univers de la
cycyber sécurité en Chine. C'est
unun grand fournisseur de
tetechnologie de service dans ls
cocommunications 5G. C'est une
cocompagnie qui fait des affairs
unun peu partout dans le monde i
esest coté en bourse à l'étrang.
C'C'est vraiment une préoccupatn
dede pays qui partagent les mêms
vavaleurs sur le plan de la
sésécurité de l'ouverture des
cocommunications et c'est
imimportant de le noter. Huawei,
vovous l'avez évoqué un peu plus
ttôt, va continuer ses activités
auau Canada, non seulement dansa
vevente des appareils
tétéléphoniques, mais Huawei a é
acaccepté au Canada depuis des
anannées comme une entreprise qi
fafait de la recherche au Canada
enen collaboration avec les
memeilleures universités
cacanadiennes, Polytechnique à
MoMontréal, au Huawei à un cente
dede recherche important, à
CaCanada, près d'Ottawa, dodonc
HuHuawei est très présent dans a
rerecherche au Canada. Est-ce qe
c'c'est comme ça qu'on a pu
évévaluer les systèmes édeer que
HuHuawei en sait trop? Je ne le
sasais trop moi non plus, mais
HuHuawei est un citoyen d'affais
cacanadien maintenant connu et
cecette décision était prise en
coconnaissance de cause. Les
ChChinois vont faire attention e
nene pas gâcher les relations
fufutures et les projets futurse
HuHuawei avec le Canada.
- - Mais comme vous le dîtes si
bibien, ils en ont plein les brs
avavec la crise de la COVID à
ShShanghai. La politique de COVD
zézéro, la pression est
ininsoutenable.
- - À Pékin aussi dans une
ququaranta